i thought we were only getting a normal
amount of lunchables and we're getting
all the lunchables i have to finish
every lunchable what do you have to say
for yourself
you told me you're gonna beat me that's
not how you beat me don't listen to him
he's been cheating look that's the mad
face can i zoom in
of the mad face i thought it was over
you thought it was a game we just get
started will you do this challenge again
oh my god
hi my name is sean i'm andrew and for
the next week
we will only be eating lunchables two
grown men
eating lunchables for a week are you not
excited i'm excited i'm not excited
one of each right
literally just go down
grab some lunchables grab some
lunchables this is the face of a man who
regrets
signing up to a challenge to eat that
like
i just want you all to know that i've
never felt so unashamed
all right that was the proudest moment
of my life i waited 13 years
for the day where i could push a
shopping cart filled with lunchables
sushi knows she knows but yeah we did go
buy the the lunchables already
and sean broke the machine hopefully we
need help
wait why we don't need help because the
system realizes this is too many
i think this is yeah it was the area it
was like these are two grommets
not halfway through and the machine
broke and then coming to
something you know i will say though
that is too many lunchables there's way
too many vegetables
this is way more than i thought it's way
too many vegetables
all right so here are the rules rule
number one we have to eat at least three
lunchables a day
rule number two you can't omit or
substitute any parts of the lunchable
rule number three you can't add any
additional ingredients
except spices or condiments and the last
thing is we can't eat
two of the same kind throughout this
challenge all right so
when are we starting i think it starts
[Music]
now you have to eat all of these
by yourself i'm serious like by yourself
[Music]
okay we'll see we'll see how this goes
anybody like any ham and swiss lunch no
you can't
i ate sweet jesus this is about to be
the best week of my entire life
look at this fridge
[Music]
look at my fridge oh my god
i feel like a little kid right now i
legit have like
a lunch box full of lunchables and i'm
like bringing to work with me
this is ridiculous but this is what it
takes to win i'm coming for you sean
we're not done yet let's go
okay first of all i should mention that
this was not a competition in the first
place i don't know where you got this
from
life is a challenge so it's literally
the first day
of this challenge and this is the best
lunch menu i've seen
all year so i'm gonna try to sneak in
but lunch is almost over and uh finesse
myself a plate
so that's the plan
he thinks he's slick but he's not
oh and uh it's the first time yeah which
is
the most important day it's the most
important i can start tomorrow
you already quit it's literally day one
and you quit so what am i gonna do for
the bet
i'll take it or you quit
do you quit before you even had your
first lunchable
look at him why are you laughing you've
got a full-on
sub here oh my god there's 510 calories
in there oh wow
you should be full you shouldn't want
anything after this
you're the one who calls me fat every
day i do not do that
i literally have never i think we
remember lunchables as like
a shared experience i have a lunchable
you have a lunchable
so i really approach this challenge
where how can i recreate those intimate
moments
andrew tell the people what you're
making okay oh my goodness
oh my goodness oh my god
why do you have so much sauce on one
area of the pizza you gotta spread it
around
doing it for a bite i'm gonna take a
nice bite no you don't that's not how
you do it
yo see this is how this is why i know
why this man is always complaining now
about this pizza electric pool because
he never made it right
you did that on purpose you literally
did that on purpose so glad to leave my
body didn't want to eat it
i promise you how did you need to do
that all right you and cold food what is
wrong with you
because it's not there are great cold
food but this pizza wasn't even cooked
to begin with it's a raw pizza
so we got pizza for lunch today
cute what you got you got pizza for
lunch today we all got pizza for lunch
today
extra cheesy here's the trick
glass of spices
[Music]
i look pretty good you look pretty good
right yeah
[Music]
honest reaction don't lie don't lie
reminds me of third grade
all right i'm two for two today i've
been sneaking my lunchables into all my
meetings
i'm walking into another one let's see
if i can go three for three
was there any other kind of like after
thing like was there food and all that
yes there was food
juices and then there was like a whole
networking event
did you like experiment with any of the
food or you just kind of ate it i was
doing it i think the most
experimentation i did was
i had so much sriracha
[Music]
so remind me again what was your
favorite my favorite was the turkey and
sub
unloaded the turkey and the sub up the
turkey sub unloaded upload it
upload it yeah um she didn't eat these
no i did
really didn't um i did the reason i say
unloaded was because
oh i see okay in through the front out
through the bag i got it
nice little bun okay here we go
you know what this is gonna be fun you
said i had to eat three at least three a
day
i did and i made them fun you were born
i was a fun lunchable eater how do you
do it at the bodegas
you know gotta do it how do you do the
bodegas where you put it down and you
fold it a little bit
peel them things off like that mm-hmm
well i just broke the cheese
put that down like that it arranged that
like that look at that
it's looking like a tasty video look at
that if we were like
single parents they would go to my house
because i'm the fun house because our
lunchables have alcohol
and parties through yeah that's the
message you want you want to send to
oscar meyer's main demographic
um that's how you lunchable that's how
you lunchable
i got it good i liked how i shipped it
out yeah how did that turn out um
it was fun so i just ended up doing the
same thing with the nachos too
i warmed up the nacho cheese you weren't
i wanted to you warmed up the nachos
that's a oh my god who eats cold nachos
get a combination i
you have a little on the corner
what's my least favorite there's too
many cracker varieties all right there's
way too many cracker varieties that was
i was good with the cracker varieties
i was good with that yeah i'm about to
go to sleep it's late i don't wanna eat
too heavy so i'm gonna try this naturals
one
all right let's make one let's jump
right in and see how many oreos we get
we get two or oh this is a double stuff
this oreo dick
this natural hit good i like this it
goes down easy
[Music]
salad lunchables solid one surprising
thing i should say
was i lost like six pounds this week
before this challenge i usually weigh in
right around
140 141 right now i currently weigh
1 35 what the frick
but i would say i do feel kind of
sluggish
like my body does feel different right
yeah which is why
he caught me that one time what not one
time that one time
andrew you were in the lunchables
challenge yes
how many times have you cheated i
am very stable oh wait look look who it
is
look who it is
all right so it's the weekend and i
happened to come by the office
and guess what i just so happen to find
this man's box of lunchables still at
work
wow how many times have you cheated i've
not cheated once
all right so i don't know what you're
talking about look at this fake ass
okay i should record it i'm recording it
so i was harassed
earlier for not having lunchables in my
hands and now what do we see over here
hmm how did them chips taste what are
you eating
what day is it of the lunchables
challenge i cheated
all right you happy so which one i
cheated show us the bagel
all right define cheating
cheat by not like we put the rules at
the beginning
and we've been following them to a
certain extent
have you been mostly eating lunchables i
would say my
my diet right now is about 35
65 leaning toward regular food
why is that so high what why is it 35
that's so high how many what percentage
of logicals are you eating
probably 80
mystery solved another day
another lunchable good morning
we're starting with um turkey and
cheddar
so i went even bigger this time this is
like a triple
decker lunchable see how it tastes
mm-hmm
five stars ten out of ten perfect wait i
mean
the challenge was fun i you know i
actually did it unlike someone else
i recall a much different outcome
because i thought i'd seen somebody
eating chips in a pretty lackadaisical
way
and somebody's mom was in town and i
know his mom's a foodie i know his mom
alright you know what insert footage
right now of me at a restaurant eating
lunchable still
all right so i'm currently out eating
lunch with my lovely mother and uh she
just flew into town and i brought her to
my favorite restaurant
she's eating my favorite food
and i'm here eating a lunchables
yeah it's my life now
what were the rules at least eat three
lunchables you don't have to eat all of
them
so what do you do with the rest of your
vegetables well i mean i still ate them
i ate all my lunchables too did you
really
every last one
i mean your camera too every last one
i've been dreading eating these pizza
lunchables so i saved them all to the
end
whatever i don't eat i'm just gonna feed
to her it kinda counts
we have the same dna so i guess it
counts as like i'm eating all of them
loophole you know i think those
instructions that i told you you just
completely omitted them
i did you omitted those instructions i
really did
what do you think braxton
i think i found somebody to give it to i
would love like
a chicken wing lunchable or what about
what about a burrito lunchable
no you know they have taco lunchables
there's tacos why don't we have a taco
you gave me 17 pizza lunchables and i
couldn't get one taco lunchable
so tonight is the final night of the
week-long lunchables challenge
i got my sriracha so you know i'm ready
today
and here we go some people have seen us
with the lunchables and then they
confided in us like we are also in the
lunchable lovers club
so there's a whole portion of adults who
eat lunchables too yes so we see you
guys
this video is for you we stand with you
guys you can afford it now you're
allowed to buy as many lunchables as you
want
maybe not 62. maybe not 62 but in
moderation yes yeah
[Music]
in the end i don't think it was that bad
of a experience
no i thought it was cool yeah i joke
around a lot but it did give me major
nostalgia
because eating them took me back there
and even
sharing that moment with my daughter she
allowed me to kind of step back in time
for a second so that was pretty cool so
it was a nice moment
again it's not about the taste it really
is about the experience yeah
never in a million years do i think i
would get a chance to eat
lunch or pools for an entire week as a
kid i'd like if the six and
seven-year-old versions of us were
sitting here today
they would be excited yeah i think the
best part about lunchables
is the the joy of sharing it with the
people you care most about
can you stop reaching in with him
like i'm trying to have a very
sentimental moment there you just
[Music]
i would do this again you would would
you really i would do this again perfect
perfect because we're actually doing
another one
adults eat kid cuisine for a week coming
very soon
oh man look out for that one or i'll
just do it again because you know
obviously
i'm the only one who doesn't cheat in
these challenges so
[Music]